انسحاب فوضوي هكذا وصفت اداره الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن انسحاب الولايات
المتحده في اغسطس 2021 من افغانستان ملكيه
ان اللوما على الرئيس السابقي دونالد
ترامب لفشله في التخطيط للانسحاب المتفق
عليه مع طالبان
ملخص لاداره الامريكيه من 12 صفحه ماخوذ
من مراجعات سريه لوزارتي الخارجيه والدفاع
واحيلت الى الكونجرس يحمل الملخص بعض
المسؤوليه عن فوضى عمليه الانسحاب
والاجلاء على تقييمات مخابراتيه وعسكريه
امريكيه فشلت في التنبؤ بسرعه سيطره
طالبان على السلطه مع توقعات بان تسيطر
قوات الامن الافغانيه على كابول
جاء في ملخص المراجعات ان خيارات بايدن
بشان كيفيه تنفيذ الانسحاب من افغانستان
كانت مقيده بشده بالظروف التي خلقها سلفه
ترامب حيث لم تقدم الاداره السابقه اي خطط
لكيفيه اجراء الانسحاب النهائي او اجلاء
الامريكيين والحلفاء الافغان كما تضمن
الملخص الغاء اداره ترامب انذاك خدمات دعم
اللاجئين وايقافه معالجه تاشيرات الهجره
الخاصه بالاف الافغان الذين عملوا لصالح
الحكومه الامريكيه
المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي جون كاربي
دافع عن قرار بايدن بالانسحاب وشدد على
العمل الذي قامت به الاداره بمجرد توليها
منصبها
قال الرئيس بايدن عمليه صنع قرار مدروسه
وصارمه وشامله ركز بشده على الحاجه الى
التخطيط السليم في الواقع وجه الرئيس بيضا
كبار قاده الامن القومي لديه للبدء في
التخطيط للانسحاب حتى قبل ان يتخذ القرار
النهائي بمغادره افغانستان
الرئيس الجمهوري للجنه العلاقات الخارجيه
بمجلس النواب الامريكي مايكل ماكول انتقد
لاداره الامريكيه بشده قائلا ان بايدن امر
بالانسحاب وبالتالي مسؤولا عن الاخفاقات
الهائله في التخطيط والتنفيذ للانسحاب
الذي انهى اطول حرب امريكيه
رش خياط العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات